Gänsehaut ich habe
[Musik]
drei Jahre zwei eins oh
nee nee hatte das geschickt Alter oh
mein Gott
mein Herz pocht richtig richtig zu Hause
ich bin absolut gar nicht bereit geht's
los
[Musik]
das sieht noch so clean aus wie ein
bisschen wie im Krankenhaus so eine so
was sieht außenrum wäre auch geil
gewesen ich bin ein Mensch jetzt diese
Lichter genau
[Musik]
aber das hat nichts von
ja das ist nicht das was wir es muss so
widerspricht von außen erkennbar sein
das gehört dazu
[Musik]
also wir haben uns die Zeit genommen und
sind drüber geflogen nach Istanbul weil
dort unsere Möbel produziert werden wenn
es halt online entdeckt wir haben
gesehen ah okay da ist ein Betrieb der
hat richtig drauf so individuelle Möbel
zu designen nach unseren Vorstellungen
da gibt es ja immer so coole Spots da
kann man sich ganz cool inspirieren
lassen auf jeden Fall auf aber trotzdem
ist halt das Risiko da weil wir halt
diesen Menschen auch nicht kannten
deswegen gerade gesagt komm wir nehmen
uns jetzt drei Tage Zeit wir fliegen
rüber wir lernen ihn kennen und wir
lernen auch so die Produktionsstätte
kennen und das haben wir halt gemacht
und das war finde ich schon so ein
bisschen beruhigend dann in dem Moment
anders
was Neues haben so einen neuen Trend
reinbringen nach Deutschland ne wir sind
individuell ja und ich habe ja
eigentlich so eine kleine so ein
moodboard gemacht mit den Farben mit der
Art der Möbel ich möchte einfach total
amateurhaft habe es ihm rüber geschickt
ja und dann hat er das irgendwie so
hinbekommen ja wie wir das wollten naja
was später kam mir ja keine Ahnung
können aber in dem Moment war alles
super
[Musik]
heute war da und da hinten kommen
so geil
und ich glaube links und rechts dann
noch diese diese Zeichnungen oder es ist
too much also Mitte ist geil aber die
Seiten sind jetzt ein bisschen nackig
Vorderseite und dass du so die Rück
Seite muss das aber irgendwie so ein
bisschen nach links schieben damit die
diese Rückseite nicht halbiert ist ist
doch viel getrennt so
guck mal jetzt also das was du meinst
ist dass die Rückseite jetzt ne wobei
die Rückseite fängt doch schon hier
macht das doch auf die Seite nein es
gibt doch keine vorderrückseite siehst
du diese Rand noch mal dazwischen
das ist das hier ja dann gehen wir mal
zurück ist das hier
in der Küche
nehme sagen wir mal ist das ja
das ist die Vorderseite und hier ist die
Rückseite
wir haben das Problem dass das hier der
Kleber ist vom Becher hier ist ein
unschöner Knick das heißt der darf nicht
im Fokus sein
das hier darfst du nicht als Rückseite
sehen der Knick ist unsere Seite
weil wenn du den Becher komplett
ausnutzen willst das ist ja dumm den
Knick als Rückseite zu sehen vorne eine
schöne Grafik zu haben die Option hier
eine schöne Grafik zu haben und auf der
Rückseite eine schöne Grafik zu haben
das heißt dein Knick ist an der Seite
und nicht und nicht hinten als wie so
ein Reißverschluss sondern
Seitenreißverschluss
nur die Vorderseite nutzen die Rückseite
musst du auch ausnutzen und gerne auch
okay warte mal wo ist die Seite
hier ist ja richtig das hier minimal
hierhin schiebt nicht ganz zum Rand
minimal hier hin kannst
du denkst dir so scheiße die hatte Recht
eine heiße Kunst haben
was dann kann man auch so Sachen
verkürzen und dann muss man nicht noch
um 0:15 Uhr wenn der Wecker um 7 Uhr
morgens klingelt hier in der Küche sind
morgen früh auf Youtube hier ja tue
deine Vorderseite okay
Knick interessiert keinen an dieser
Seite und deine Rückseite eine zweite
Fläche um was schönes aufzudrucken und
du wolltest nur eine Fläche haben weißt
du was Entschuldigung
also ganz viele Fragen ja auch immer wie
ist das eigentlich so mit seinem Mann zu
arbeiten also das war so eine der vielen
Situationen wo wir so zwei verschiedene
Meinungen waren
einfach nur Freunde man diskutiert aber
darüber dass normal in dem Fall schaltet
man ab dass man verheiratet man sagt
einfach okay sind Geschäftspartner genau
man ist in dem Moment halt wirklich
Business Partner und den nächsten Moment
abends wenn dann die Business Sache
erledigt ist
und Trinken unseren Sofa ja es ist oft
so dass wir gerade bei dem Thema
Ruhrpark und Store und Kaffee haben wir
oft Meinungsverschiedenheit sagen kommt
ja noch was wo du mich auch richtig
aufgeregt hast aber ich habe dich auch
wirklich schon machen lassen habe und
die wo ich am Ende dein mistausbildung
ist aber okay
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so wir haben ja das stäbchenparkett von
witwitz übernehmen müssen und das haben
wir natürlich rausgehauen auch wenn
stäbchenpakete ich glaube relativ teuer
ist so ein und dann so 20.000 Mal
irgendwo verteilt das muss man draußen
dann braucht alles für unterschiede gibt
es gibt extra rutschfeste Fliesen gerade
für
einzelhandelsläden und matt und
Supermarkt und glänzend es gibt so viel
wir Romero Fliesen und haben uns da dann
glaube ich am gleichen Tag noch weil wir
auch so ganz schon relativ gestresst
schon zu dem Zeitpunkt
genau das musst Du schnell gehen und wir
mussten schnell entscheiden und es gab
einige zur Auswahl im hellen Bereich wir
wollten im hellen Bereich bleiben auch
immer glaube ich mehr wisch und
Putzarbeit später haben aber sieht halt
einfach schicker aus und haben uns
glaube ich am gleichen Tag noch
entschieden und wollten dass es auch
relativ schnell geliefert wird
das sind solche Dinge Romero Fliesen
jetzt drauf
[Musik]
dass du gekommen
Alexa
viel besser jetzt ist es ein schöner
Flair boah das ist richtig fresh aus
jetzt haben sie erzähl mal wie viele
Song Sebastian Cheesecakes habe ich so
gebacken insgesamt ich glaube
eine Spitze so
zählst du gerade
gerade durch ich kann nicht so 15 15 ich
kann das nicht ich muss mal Stück Stück
für Stück 10
fürs Kaffee allein dafür schon jetzt so
in den letzten Wochen
also ich glaube insgesamt locker locker
100 ja insgesamt ja und jetzt nur fürs
Kaffee weil ich kann nicht die gleiche
Rezeptur nehmen wie online auf Youtube
gehen funktioniert nicht mehr weil ich
möchte ihn höher haben und der wird in
so einem industriebackofen gebacken es
ist alles nicht so einfach Leute aber
bei mir kommen nur original Kikis
kitchen Vanilleextrakt rein ja nur ich
muss sagen ich mache es nur mit
Philadelphia ja
aber dafür
sage ich ja also es ist eine Frischkäse
Zubereitung und deshalb ist ja auch so
gut geeignet für
für Cheesecakes weil das so salzarm
schmeckt
[Musik]
wo muss ich drücken
ja okay also ist dieser
auf dein Gesicht gedrückt ne
so machen
so Versuch nun mal 350 damit einfach
perfekt wird die perfekte Höhe auch
bekommt
also es ist ja klar dass wir auch den
Song Sebastian Cheesecake anbieten das
war so von vorne rein das Ding also ich
glaube es wäre auch schon fast ein
Skandal wenn wir den nicht anbieten
würden nachdem wir den Halt mega mega
gehyped haben ich kann natürlich nicht
selber backen ist ja klar ich kann ihn
in meiner Küche mit meinem Ofen außerdem
habe ich keinen Konditor schein also ich
kann ihn einfach nicht selber backen
aber das soll genau dann mache ich ja
nichts anderes
schaffe ich ja gar nichts mehr
das wichtigste ist nach meinem Rezept
ein Konditor der mich versteht der das
mit mir zusammen entwickelt weil man
kann nicht einfach das Rezept nehmen was
ich auf Youtube habe und in ein
gastrobackofen schieben da werden 15 20
San Sebastian Cheesecakes auf einmal
gesagt und
kommt worauf wir später kamen wir wollen
ein viel breiteren Kuchen das heißt wir
brauchen viel mehr Zutaten und viel mehr
Masse weil der richtig schön hoch sein
soll da kann man halt einfach nicht auch
ich habe ja auch nur eine 20er Form in
meinem Rezept und das mussten wir
ausbreiten auf eine größere Form und die
Herausforderung war das wirklich in so
einem gastrobackofen hinzubekommen und
da konnten wir selbst die Konditoren
nicht helfen ich war mit so vielen in
Kontakt sein seit letztes Jahr also
wirklich ihr müsst euch vorstellen ich
glaube das sind jetzt acht Monate jetzt
vergangen sind schon heftig also keiner
kannte den nicht wirklich also wir
mussten immer erklären und haben sich
irgendwie verbrannt ist okay alles klar
und da haben die immer erst mal gebacken
wo der nicht verbrannt war und dann muss
das erklären eine Mutter verbrannt sein
ich sag also es ist kein
also der muss schon eigentlich schon
diese Farbe haben ne
die Farbe dass der schön glatt ist diese
feuchtigkeitslinie das Vanille mag dass
man den richtigen okay also Frischkäse
verwendet dass man nicht auf Zutat es
gibt natürlich auch wieder
verschiedenste Qualitäten das Qualität
immer an oberster ist und das war so
schmecken so wie du den auf Video
gemacht hast Punkt
heißt das Video dann stand auch die Idee
von unserer von mir bis er sagt dass wir
irgendwann Kaffee machen ja ganz ehrlich
muss das Anbieten und genau am besten
diese Kuchen
aber haben sie das Schaf
[Musik]
ist dem Mittwoch kommt die Fliesen
Mittwochabend kommen die Fliesen aber
einpacken
oder wir kriegen Schlüssel vom Würfel
nein
es beginnt es geht los
[Musik]
krass oder
das sieht richtig schön aus im Laden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alleine ich würde sie alleine
komplett alleine wie war es 80 €
mit Treppe hoch können die nur drüber
lachen ich glaube ihr macht ihr macht
schon ganz andere ganz andere
Quadratmeter
[Musik]
du meinst wahrscheinlich unsere
versetzen
dass man das Gefühl hat man ist bei dir
zu Hause in der Küche
[Musik]
so die Nacht war also eine lange Nacht
wir haben aber auch extra
entkoffeinierten Kaffee gebrüht die
ganze Zeit weil sonst der war glaube ich
so und würden gar nicht schlafen also
die eigenen Kaffeekreationen sind schon
so ein ein Herzstück des Cafés ist ja
auch ein Coffee-to-go und ich glaube
gerade dann so kalte Kaffeegetränke
du bist ja immer irgendwas kaltes haben
privat immer so coole Kombis zusammen
und fürs Kaffee haben wir dann wirklich
uns auch
gemacht das war auch wichtig für die
Firma für meine becherkonstruktion da
Grafik weil wir haben ja so ein
spezielles System was wir dann machen
wollen und dann brauchen wir diese
Striche im Becher und dann müssen wir
wissen wie viel kommen was reinkommt
damit der Mitarbeiter spielt das einfach
hat okay bisschen Strich wird gefüllt
okay da muss ich die Grafik da ansetzen
damit der Mitarbeiter weiß damit auch
alles schnell geht das war ein gutes
zuspielen also du warst irgendwie so
klar du probierst auch ein bisschen der
beste testtester der Welt gleichzeitig
hast du auch diese Becher konstruiert im
Endeffekt haben wir ganz viel ganz viel
ausprobiert ganz viel rausgeflogen es
muss halt zu 1000 Prozent schmecken und
da haben wir wirklich nur das genommen
was mega lecker ist es müssen auch
hochwertige Zutaten sein wir haben zum
Beispiel auch was Sirup angeht haben wir
uns da auch durch verschiedene Firmen
getestet bis sie gemerkt haben der muss
so intensiv sein der Sirup das war sogar
kurze Zeit überlegt haben unseren
eigenen herstellen zu lassen wenn es
dann und jetzt so entstehen halt auch
neue Produkte und jetzt sind wir dabei
unseren eigenen Sirup herstellen zu
lassen tatsächlich nach unseren
Anforderungen weil die waren alle so ein
bisschen Lush also die waren irgendwie
nicht so weiß ich nicht und so sind
unsere Ideen entstanden
machen gleich bist
es schmeckt sehr Herbst extrem her es
ist was für die die einen Kaffee nicht
so süß mögen
[Musik]
es sieht geil aus ja man der sieht echt
lecker aus ihr müsst mal probieren ne
vielleicht schmeckt er ja gar nicht
weiß es einfach geil ist einfach geil
runter richtig lecker aber ich finde es
schmeckt zu wenig nach Karamell
jedes Mal schmeckt jetzt total intensiv
so ich finde es ein bisschen zu viel am
Boden so viel weniger
das Getränk an sich bewerten ich hätte
gerne ein Karamell frappé
oder etwas
bitte schön
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich geschmacklich geiler
Eiskaffee aber aber irgendwie fehlt mir
der Bezug zur Farbe boah das sieht mega
aus
Schokolade sehr kalt wird ja die könnte
so ein bisschen antrocknen
koffeinfrei ist aber das schmeckt
richtig geil aber es dauert es keinen
Tag oh mein Favorite dieser einfach
Vanillegeschmack knappen Abgang ist geil
Vanille und weiße Schokolade ist so ein
Mensch das passt immer zusammen
[Musik]
helfen würde
abklären lässt dann wären die Sachen
allerspätestens am 15 in Deutschland
buchen sagte aber es ist am 15 ist genau
der letzte Arbeitstag von den
Ladenbauern die sind für die 28
Kalenderwoche geblockt also komplett für
die nächste Woche aber wenn er sagt es
ist Freitag ja scheiße
dass die Zeit ist halt nur das doofe
jetzt also da muss ich mein Markus mal
sprechen ob die vielleicht sogar erst
mitte ende der Woche anfangen und dann
Anfang der Woche weiter machen ohne
außenrückgabe gibt es keinen Laden
haben Designern in der Art musst du auch
Leuchten das muss cool aussehen ne das
ist echt nicht so einfach und das ist
echt nicht so günstig wenn man denkt
ohne Spaß das ist echt teuer
die die du gar nicht so ein Blick
hattest und dann denkst du wie so aus
Scheiße das haut uns jetzt wieder so ein
bisschen raus
also sich da kommt schon was auch nicht
zu und du bist einfach so ein Licht
verrückt ne die in der Wohnung diese bei
dir muss ja alles Leuchten ne vom Gefühl
wir haben jetzt dann zu unserem Kikis
kitchen Schriftzug Logo weil ein Logo
wäre durch gewesen
haben wir quasi dann so konzipieren
lassen und noch einmal im Café für vorne
Ordnung ja wobei der kommt Logo hin und
nochmal innen drinnen Logo noch mal
innen drin ein Schriftzug Logo was
leuchtet Neon und noch mal ganz oben
außen dass man auch von ganz weit weg
ist
also wir suchen jetzt gerade in
reitturnen von den Schränken ich finde
das schlimmste ist Farbe auszusuchen das
ist stresst einem richtig
einfach in dieser Leiste also rechts
links sozusagen
[Musik]
aber ich glaube hier ist schön finde die
alle nicht so finde die alle nicht so
toll wenn ich ehrlich bin einfach ganz
ehrlich kurzen Prozess wenn man könnte
jetzt stundenlang gucken welchen rosa
Ton welchen pastelltod ey ihr habt
keinen Bock darauf ne das ist so eine
Entscheidung die die fällst du nie weil
das immer einen Ton gibt der schöner ist
als der andere so dann machen wir die
weiß ne
zwei es gemacht
aber es ist
Büros
scheiße das ist echt zu knallig ne ich
hoffe das sieht doch verwandt nicht so
aus okay ich hoffe das ist einfach gut
aussehen wird ja dann gehen
[Musik]
oh oh oh
jetzt kann man nicht so richtig
vorstellen
richtig schön
[Musik]
und dann kam der Markus mit seiner
Truppe der Markus ist eigentlich
Küchenspezialist das ist ja Mörder
weniger eine Küche im Kaffee aber schon
sehr speziell also ist schon eine sehr
sehr
gut diese Holzkonstruktion gebaut also
eigentlich sollten Trockenbau kommen und
dann so eine Wand hochziehen und dann
hat der Max der weiße was den brauchen
wir nicht das mache selber jetzt ne und
dann quasi aus Spanplatten ne haben wir
quasi eine Holzkonstrukt also echt alles
Handarbeit ist echt haben die alles vor
Ort geschnitten schon heftig also Markus
der ist ein echten arrown also echter in
Team der Markus ist ein Allrounder und
der ist auch voll das Brain also der
denkt über fünf Ecken da würden wir
beide gar nicht drauf kommen und
deswegen war das einfach so Gold wert
dass er mit seinem Kindergarten also
diese Zeichnung das hat er konzentriert
alles ne also er hat gesagt kommt da da
kommt da kommt Strom da kommt das hin da
kommen die Platte muss so hoch sein als
noch der alles ne genau das war alles
von ihm also da haben wir uns
zusammengesetzt aber er hatte halt so
diese Ideen er hat ja auch Erfahrung
muss man einfach dazu sagen ne der hat
auch ja es ist schon eine sehr sehr
spezielle Anfertigung die an den Store
im Store hat er uns natürlich auch ein
bisschen was von ihm mit mit rein
gegeben also wir haben jetzt auch im
Store was von ihm also ein Küchenelement
auch wenn alles drumherum quasi diese
Regal Anfertigungen waren ne genau aber
auch da konnte der uns also es ist immer
super jemanden dabei zu haben der
einfach und so ein bisschen den Weg
zeigt wirklich begabt ist weil ich kann
die Kasse also alles programmieren aber
so Schrauben und so
[Musik]
eine Karte bis hier hinten die wir dann
hier so reinsetzen
so irgendwie kam ja durch Hamza die Idee
mit dem Bögen so auf einmal waren die
Bögen auf diesem coffee to go-bechern
die waren auf einmal da und dann haben
wir angefangen diese schönen Bögen auf
die Tüten
das war halt voll der Zufall diese Bögen
mit diesen rosa Farbverlauf das ist
jetzt irgendwie unser Ding und dann
machen wir diese Böden so als Instagram
Spot wir wollten nicht mehr diese
Schaukeln diese flügelschaufel weil
diese Flügel sind ein bisschen billig
aus man hat ja auch schon gefühlt
überall gesehen
und dann jemanden zu finden mit dem man
noch nie gearbeitet hat der dich aber
versteht und dass du hinbekommen war
auch noch mal so
[Musik]
das beste Baustellen
ja damit bauen wir den ganzen Store
gerade
das ist der magische
[Musik]
du bist super toll
merkt euch also mein Kühlschrank kauft
muss man eigentlich noch mal so 5 Euro
Entsorgungspauschale und einrechnen
[Musik]
ja dann war es schön stressig nach der
Hochzeit genau aber vorher noch auf
einer Hochzeit für zwei Stunden und sind
dann rüber zum Ruhrpark und dann ist er
die Anlieferung aus der Türkei gekommen
weil wir dachten die Möbel kommen 22 Uhr
der kam sie doch erst um 23:30 Uhr das
heißt diesen früheren Hochzeit gegangen
und muss auch noch warten ja das Problem
ist ja auch wir konnten ja mit dem LKW
irgendwie nicht die Rampe hoch und wir
mussten dann von ganz weit weg wie viel
Meter ran das 50 60 m diese extrem
schweren Regale schleppen also ihr
besser gesagt also ich persönlich
komplett quasi die Regale drinne und der
durfte halt nicht ganz einfach weil er
hat einfach schwer war und das Problem
ist ja auch jetzt bei uns im Center und
darf nur ab 20 Uhr was machen oder ab
oder vor 10 Uhr morgens mit mittags geht
sowas gar nicht das heißt wir mussten
das abends machen und äh boah das war so
anstrengend ey das war so anstrengend
das ist so schief gelaufen ja nicht mal
richtig was zum Tragen gehabt zum Rollen
gehabt wir wussten ja nicht dass wir
nicht vor dem Laden Paten dürfen und da
muss ja noch Leute besorgen die das
machen ne ist auch nicht so einfach weil
die Crew besteht zu 95% aus aus Mädchen
im Endeffekt und deswegen muss ich halt
schnell Jungs besorgen war schwierig und
es ist echt so einfach ein paar Stunden
so eine Mannschaft auf der Trommel ne
und ich hatte sogar zu wenig gehabt aber
trotzdem schön dass diejenigen die Zeit
hatten wirklich gekommen sind einfach
mal ganz random nachts nachts zum Möbel
tragen bis 3 Uhr morgens tatsächlich ja
so dann kam ja irgendwann der Sonntag da
durfte man auch tagsüber den ganzen Tag
dort arbeiten weil das hinterher
geschlossen war und dann hieß es alle
großen Möbel noch mal rausschleppen
und dann sortieren auch erstmal so
welcher Schranken kommt ja da war auch
keinerlei Bezeichnung drauf was ist
jetzt in welchem Paket versteckt warum
das war so ein Stress für uns und das
sollte aber eigentlich war auch total
aufgeregt einen Tag das sollte
eigentlich der allerschönste Tag sein
weil man hat irgendwie fünf Monate drei
Monate im Voraus schon das ganze Design
das ganze Konzept geplant man weiß auf
der 3D-Grafik wie das aussieht und dann
ist der Moment wo sie endlich in Bochum
ankommen und man alles aufmacht Anreiz
sich anschaut und einfach nur noch denkt
okay jetzt befülle ich die Regale und
dann kam alles anders als gedacht so
eine Scheiße
so eine scheiße sein
alle gemeinsam
es ist
schön es ist es ist schön aber es ist
nicht das was wir uns gedacht haben guck
mal das Ding ist du kommst rein es ist
gar kein Mädchentraum nein das Problem
ist der hat gesagt ich mache ich
Pastelltöne und auch versetzt er hat ja
noch 0,0 Absprache gehalten scheiße
das ist sehr schön auf jeden Fall ist
das das ist einfach kacke Hamza ich lese
letzten zu Hause auf dem Kalender
einfach schon der 18 ich hoffe bitte sag
mal soll ich lachen oder weinen ist doch
schön ja ist das schön fällt dir nichts
auf da dran
mein innerer Monk so eigentlich machst
du ein Zeilenumbruch
Hamza habe ich ihm aber auch gesagt ich
hätte mich echt mal einmischen sollen
bei diesem Thema weißt du was aber Kiki
Kiki weißt du was ohne Spaß ich habe
diesen Fehler mit der Küche gemacht
damals deswegen ich lass dich jetzt
alleine entscheiden
dass du dass du bei jeder Sache sagst ja
ich habe etwas gesagt du weißt es doch
nicht scheiße
hallo alles gut alles wird gut
komm zeig mal liebe oi oi alles wird
gut wir haben heute Dienst Montag
Freitag ist es alles rosa also chill ja
alles gut
fünf Sachen die schief gelaufen sind
nichts mit zu tun
[Musik]